así
buen trabajo probablemente descubriste
que modificar la escala de la base
modifica la escala del brazo y la escala
de la cabeza esto es porque las escalas
se afectan una a la otra cuando trabajas
con controles como el de formador de
escala que afectan a todo el modelo oa
muchas de sus piezas
es mejor determinar correctamente la
escala global antes de trabajar con las
piezas individuales a esto le llamamos
trabajar de boceto a final ya tenemos
todos los conceptos necesarios para
modelar y articular la lámpara ahora
puedes agregar escalas a tu lámpara para
hacerla parecer más joven o mayor agrega
rotaciones a todas las articulaciones
para que puedas hacer pasar a la lámpara
agrega controles para trasladar y rotar
a la base para que puedas moverla y
acabando el ejercicio tenemos un extra
que te permitirá intentar animar su
lámpara articulada definitivamente debes
echarle un vistazo a la lección de
animación antes de intentar eso